could have a big impact i mean it's
important to remember that we're all
entitled to opinions aren't we but when
it comes to the monarchy and opinions on
politics or policy they are expected to
keep these to themselves i mean fearless
to prince charles these comments were
allegedly said in a private conversation
with someone that then leaked these
comments to the press now during those
conversations he apparently called these
government plans to send some asylum
seekers to rwanda as appalling he also
spoke about the fact that later this
month he will become the first member of
the royal family to actually visit
rwanda for a summit for the commonwealth
heads of government and spoke about the
fact that he allegedly claimed that he
worries that this policy will overshadow
that summit which is all about bringing
the commonwealth together and we know
that this is something that is very
important to prince charles however
as you say they haven't denied the fact
that he made these comments with
clarence house in a statement did say
that they would not comment on supposed
private conversations with the prince of
wales except to restate that he remains
politically neutral and that matters of
policy decisions are for government and
this is important the prince of the
prince charles is the ear he is the
future king and he is expected to keep
these political opinions to himself is
it the first time that he's caused
controversy with political opinions but
in recent years he has remained quiet on
these issues as i say he will eventually
become king and he's aware that he
should not be making these comments so
it is quite surprising that on an issue
that has been so contentious there's
been so many arguments and in fact those
arguments have become fights in the
courts just this week the high court
ruled that this flight is legal and that
it could still go ahead but on monday
that fight will continue in the court of
appeals so the fact that he's waiting
now is not very good timing to be quite
frank